Venga, grabación. Vale, ¿qué es lo que
estuvimos? Y vale, teníamos el ejercicio
aquel de consolidación, ¿lo habéis
subido?
A ver, era consolidación.
Lo habéis subido uno solo. Ver todos los
envíos.
Vale, lo habéis subido solo uno de
vosotros. Pues nada, eso hay que
pasarlo y lo corregimos. Eh,
vale. Y luego teníamos también el tema
de
lo tenéis hecho el ejercicio ese de
consolidación. Yo me suena que que lo
estuvimos comentando ayer también, ¿no?
Yo lo tengo en papel que te lo comenté.
Si quieres que lo saque foto.
Lo tienes en papel.
Sí.
No, no te falta que le hagas foto,
hombre. Da igual.
Vale. ¿Y alguno más lo tiene?
Yo terminado no lo tengo. Lo tengo a
medias.
Pues no sé,
enviarlo. Os dejo, os dejo un poquillo
para que lo hagáis y y lo que vamos a
ver también es el tema de las IPs,
¿vale?, que es lo que estuvimos hablando
el otro día,
¿vale? Tenemos simulacro de examen que
sería de direcciones IP,
¿vale? en el cual pues eso tenemos que
tenemos que clasificarlas en base a una
su clase a y bueno, una serie de
cuestiones relativas a
direcciones IP.
¿Vale? Mientras mientras vais haciendo
esto, me voy a instalar el la versión 9
Packet Tracer,
¿vale? Porque tengo la 8.2,
Entonces, algunos sí que me habéis
mandado ejercicios de Packet Tracer en
la versión
en la en la versión nue no los puedo
abrir.
Vale. Y a ver,
¿habéis hablado por el examen que os va
a poner la
que os va a poner pilar de pilar de
inglés?
Sí.
Que os lo va a hacer en rollo escrito,
¿no? Me imagino en
Sí, en papel. en papel. No
lo tenéis controlado más o menos o qué.
Bueno, sí. Bueno,
a ver,
vale.
Tenemos el de direcciones IP también que
teníamos un examen
que es el os he enseñado el del año
pasado, os lo enseñé el otro día,
¿vale? Este de aquí, por ejemplo, es una
parte del examen que se hizo el año
pasado, ¿vale? Entonces,
si Jorge, tú cómo lo tienes hecho o los
que tengáis hecho el de
o sea, los que tengáis hecho, espera,
voy a cerrar esto,
¿vale? Los que tengáis hecho el de
consolidación,
como es tu caso, pues no, pues vale, si
quieres te pones con ese con el
Vale, mientras y ahora lo ahora lo
corregimos todo esto.
Lo voy a pasar en PDF o en este mismo.
Le voy a cambiar el nombre, ¿vale? para
que luego no nos rayemos al día del
examen.
A ver, archivo.
Guardar. ¿Cómo hoy va a ir todo al cajón
desastre este de prueba PK?
Escritorio. ¿Dónde estamos? Dios.
Vale, está por ahí.
Vale, prueba
acá.
Os voy a os lo voy a pasar por aquí.
Eh, tenemos este.
Es que realmente os tenía otro preparado
también
porque tú este me has dicho, Jorge, que
esto lo habías hecho ya.
dijiste,
eh, comparte, porfa.
Vale, espera.
Vale, que no estoy compartiendo, es
verdad.
Vale, a ver, compartir.
Yo tan feliz creía que estaba
compartiendo.
Vale, sería este se hizo el año pasado,
¿vale? estos estos números.
Sí.
Vale. Entonces eso yo creo que este h
por lo que me has dicho tú lo copiaste,
¿no? Y lo
Sí, est haciéndolo para ver, pero
y lo estuviste haciendo. Bueno, pero lo
tienes hecho
o no o has hecho algunos.
Pues ahora mismo no sé dónde tengo el
Bueno, pues hazlo otra vez y practicas.
otra vez y prácticas para el día del del
examen, si te parece.
Vale,
venga, os lo voy a pasar, ¿vale? Por
también por aquí por el chat.
Es que no sé si ponerle alguna más.
Es que quiero Vale, vale, hay una que me
gusta. Vale, está bien,
¿eh? Luego está esta otra.
Vale,
esto, Jessica, lo habéis lo habéis
llegado a dar en revés en todo esto, el
descifrar una IP, todo esto o te suena
así un poco
Me suena chino.
¿Te suena chino?
Sí.
Bueno,
pues ahora lo ves cómo cómo se hace todo
esto. O sea, sí que sí que habréis
mirado lo que era una dirección IP, cuál
era la parte de eso
que estamos dando
la parte de red, la parte de host,
eso sí, la máscara solo he dado más,
¿vale? La clase a la que pertenece, si
es pública o privada o es reservada.
Eso sí,
como como
o sea, reder binario son las de clase A,
por ejemplo.
Sí, claro, sí, eso lo he dado.
Vale. O sea, la parte de reden binario,
por ejemplo, son las de clase A. Vale.
Bueno, venga, pues vamos a Os lo paso,
¿vale? Entonces sí que sabes hacerlo
este de aquí también.
Vale, ahora lo corregiremos. Venga, os
lo paso.
Vale. Ahí no tenéis
Vale, otra cosa, os subí ayer el
ejercicio, lo digo para los que no para
los que no estabais en no asististeis
por Zoom a la clase, os subí el
ejercicio de topologías,
¿vale? en el que el archivo de Packet
Trustter lo tenéis en el en el Google
Drive que tenemos compartido. Por
cierto, yo a ti, Jessica, no te tengo
compartida, ¿no? En el en el Google
Drive creo que no. A ver,
creo que no. Vale, a ver que te voy a
compartir.
¿Cuánto estáis? 1, dos, 3, 4, 5 6
h
Tienes de Gemil, ¿no? El correo,
Jessica.
Ahora lo miro.
Sí, sí, es Gemil. Sí, lo tengo aquí. Sí,
sí, sí, sí. Ah,
vale, lo tengo. No, no te preocupes. Ah,
vale. Hm.
Vale, ya lo tendrías por lo menos en
redes. Vale.
también
aplicaciones.
Me ha salido. Ahora
te ha salido. No tienes una carpeta que
es en la que voy poniendo el material
parte del material que vamos haciendo.
Por ejemplo, tienes el de topologías, lo
tienes como como lector, ¿vale? Y luego
tienes una carpeta para enviar
ejercicios por si para aquellos
ejercicios que no sean evaluables y pues
nada, un espacio para enviarlos.
Vale, perfecto.
Vale. Y eso es con todas las con todas
las asignaturas, ¿vale? Te lo te he dado
de alta en las bueno, te lo he
compartido solo en redes locales, pero
bueno, en las siguientes asignaturas te
lo iré poniendo también,
¿vale?
Vale, te estoy ahora verás que te llega
otro de de aplicaciones ofimáticas.
Te llegarán dos de aplicaciones
ofimáticas
y me han llegado ahora de ofimática y
tal. Me está subiendo todo ahora. Sí,
vale. Y luego pues ya las siguientes
asignaturas ya te iré poniendo.
Vale.
Vale, esto ya ya dejo de editar esto.
Vale, pues si queréis ¿Cómo lo lleváis?
Ya lo habéis acabado, estáis haciendo.
Me me queda uno.
Vale, tú estás con las IPs. Yo voy, lo
que vamos a hacer es mirarlo de
consolidación antes
y luego nos ponemos con el otro, ¿vale?
el de el de el de las IPS. Hay algunas
fake eh de IPS.
Yo estoy teniendo problemas con el Word
y todo esto que se me ha parece que se
me ha acabado la licencia o algo así.
No me digas.
Sí, y he hecho lo de las IPs y ya las
tengo más o menos bien, pero lo otro no
puedo.
Álvaro, en en Microsoft 365 puedes
entrar,
¿eh? Es que no sé si lo tengo aquí
puesto.
Vale, míralo a ver, mira el tema de
licencias y si no se lo dices a
dirección mañana por la mañana.
Vale.
Lo digo porque te va a hacer falta para
para el examen. Ya no ya no para mi
asignatura, sino para las demás.
Lo más seguro te pidan.
Es que tendré que buscar
sí
por ahí o algo, no sé, o probar en el
tres y c. Claro, en principio sería
Escucha el 365. Si tienes el si le pones
tú tienes el Word instalado.
Sí.
Vale. Si le pones la licencia del 365 te
debería de funcionar.
¿Y cómo podría mirar lo de la licencia?
La licencia es que es la que te enviaron
con la matrícula.
Ah, vale, vale,
vale. Pues lo miro yo ahora. Pero esa es
la que tendrás en el correo. Míralo a
ver porque seguro que con eso a ver
porque tú puedes abrirlo
el Word. Sí, pero no me deja editar
nada.
Vale, ábrelo, ábrelo y lo y lo vemos y
le echamos un si quieres, ¿eh? Sí. Y te
digo,
me salta lo de Sí, es la licencia.
Es la licencia, pero en
Pero que lo tenías ahí en plan piratilla
o qué. Sí, es que como era nuevo pues lo
instalé ahí pirata y no sé si estáo
regular.
Ponle ponle la ponle la licencia que
tienes del Microsoft 365 y te debería de
funcionar.
Vale, pues ahora la busco.
Vale,
vale. Vamos a mirar el tema del de este
de consolidación
a ver que me descargue.
Bueno, sí, lo tendré. descargado seis
veces ya.
Vamos a ver.
Vale, tenamos por un lado.
Vale, ¿cuáles son las principales
ventajas que proporcionan las redes de
ordenadores?
Vale, que esto es un tema así bastante
subjetivo, hombre, os podéis es en base
a lo que vienen los materiales, ¿vale? O
sea, realmente
podríamos decir que lo la compartición
de archivos,
¿vale? Eso sería una ventaja.
Comunicación y colaboración entre
usuarios, por ejemplo, sería otra.
Acceso centralizado a la información,
mayor eficiencia y reducción de costos.
¿Se os ocurre alguna más?
Vale, la siguiente, ¿qué diferencias ahí
habría entre un servicio y un protocolo?
Vale, pues un protocolo,
eh, bueno, un servicio es sería la
funcionalidad que se ofrece a los
usuarios y otros dispositivos que se
implementan mediante uno o varios
protocolos.
Por ejemplo, el servicio de de correo
electrónico que utilizaría
SMT SMTP, POP 3, etcétera. ¿Vale? Y un
protocolo es un conjunto de reglas y
estándares que definen cómo se comunican
los dispositivos en una red, por
ejemplo, el TCPIP,
¿vale? Así en a groso modo sería eso,
¿vale? ¿Cuáles de las siguientes
topologías?
¿Cuál de las siguientes son topologías
lógicas de red?
H, o sea, diferenciábamos entre las las
topologías lógicas
y las topologías físicas. ¿De acuerdo?
Eso sí que lo lo estuvimos mirando.
Las topologías lógicas hm se referirían
a la forma en que los en que los datos
fluyen en la red
independientemente de su disposición
física. ¿Vale? Entonces, por
deducción, h si no lo sabéis esto, o
sea, pues si tenemos que que topologías
físicas serían estrella, maya,
estrella, estrella extendida
y jerárquica, pues tenemos
las siguientes, ¿no?, que serían token y
broadcast,
¿vale? Y esa sería cuál es cuál de las
siguientes son topologías lógicas de
red. Pues tenemos la A y la A y la E.
¿De acuerdo?
Vale. Otra.
Un usuario se acaba de comprar una una
PCP y queda con su vecino para jugar con
él en su habitación.
¿Qué tipo de red están creando y por
qué?
Una pan. Sí,
vale. Están creando una red de una red
personal
porque eh es una red salió una red de de
corto alcance para conectar dispositivos
personales,
¿vale? en un entorno así reducido,
¿vale? La siguiente que sería asignar
los siguientes tipos de redes a sus
respectivas clasificaciones,
¿vale? redes
pan donde la incluiríamos
en lo lo hemos mirado antes. Esta sería
según su extensión su extensión, ¿no? O
sea, su principal característica es eso.
Sería sería sería eso, o sea, la
cercanía, ¿no?
Vale. Siguiente de MZ.
Aquí sería según su función. Es una red
perimetral que actúa como
que actuaría como
como zona desmilitarizada.
Esta
creo que que sí que lo estuvimos. Vamos,
yo creo que sí que están los materiales.
Está
Sí, digamos. O sea, tiene que estarse
así.
No, es que voy a repasar el
tendríamos la caracterización, ¿vale?
Esto, esto sí que lo tendríamos en la
unidad uno y luego tendríamos también un
resumen que estuvimos mirando. No.
¿Veis? Si ya lo tenemos.
A ver si es que está en otro.
No, pues parece que no viene los
en lo que serían los apuntes.
¿Cómo posible? Vamos a ver otra vez.
Eh, te mando ya eso para después.
Vale, vale, Jorge. Vale, gracias.
Bueno, luego teníamos la la DMZ. Por lo
que veo, no vienen los no vienen los
apuntes, cosa que me extraña bastante.
Ao de que la pongan con otra con otras
hijas. A ver.
No,
a ver, topología no en topologías no
estaría en las de personal es que serían
estas
según sus funciones repente.
Esa nos va a salir, ¿vale? Ya sabéis que
está
Bueno, luego las otras,
a ver, control
miramos
C.
Vaya, vaya. Bueno, vale, pues esto sí
que lo tengo en cuenta para
vale la Subelan
serían según su función
que esto sería una red virtual que se
enenta la red por función
un departamento,
parte de una organización eh
Vale.
O sea, aparte de una organización, me
refiero a eso, a un a un departamento
dentro de una organización, por ejemplo.
¿Vale? Luego estaría Han, que sería
redes según su extensión, sería home
area network,
sería una red de en el hogar,
¿vale? Y luego, ¿qué más nos estaba
diciendo? A ver,
vale, la recable que sería re según el
medio de transmisión. Estas vendrían
aquí en esta casilla,
¿vale? Y luego das que no realmente no
es una red, es un sistema de
almacenamiento.
Das NASAN. Vale,
eso ya
creo que no lo eso no lo hemos mirado,
¿no? Aquí en primero todavía
no me suena. No me suena que lo hemos
dado.
Vale. ¿Qué ventajas posen las redes
inalámbricas sobre las cableadas?
Se ocurre que se ocurre
por su principal
su principal ventaja sería que no hay
que tirar de cables,
¿vale?
Podemos tener dispositivos,
ubicarlos en el lugar que nos que
queramos sin necesidad de generar o de
tener que crear una instalación
cableada.
¿Vale? Esa sería la principal ventaja y
creo que la mayor,
¿vale? porque luego
es fácil de expandir y modificar. Podría
ser el costo. En algunos casos puede ser
más barato al no necesitar cableado.
Y eh
bueno, pues eso, o sea, movilidad
básicamente sería movilidad, ¿vale? Esas
eh,
esa por qué costo es que a lo mejor
el coste un punto wifi no lo sé, eh, o
sea, ahora mismo,
por ejemplo,
punto wifi,
PC
componentes Así.
punto de acceso wifi. Bueno, tampoco
están tan tan excesivamente caros.
Vale, pues eso, pues no sé, es a valorar
qué nos cuesta más, cable. Cable o
añadir un punto, a ver, entendiendo que
que sería una extensión, ¿vale? que lo
que sería tenemos un router que nos está
emitiendo un wifi. Nosotros lo que
queremos es duplicar esa señal wifi
mediante otro mediante un punto wifi que
lo pondamos que lo pongamos en un lugar
hacia a donde no está llegando o donde
ya está empezamos a tener una cierta
pérdida de señal,
¿vale? que a lo mejor lo ideal no es
ponerlo en modo wifi, sino llevarlo un
cable, con lo cual ya tenemos el gasto,
no sé, es que es es a valorar, ¿vale? Es
eh por eso en cuanto a costo pues a lo
mejor no es tan ventajoso, porque ahí sí
que tenemos que valorar la situación en
concreto con la que nos enfrentemos,
¿vale? Y luego sería por otro lado el
identifica el tipo de cable al que
pertenecen los siguientes conectores. BC
sería el cable coacial. Esto lo tenemos
en el temario.
En la eh ahora os lo digo,
lo tenemos en la unidad dos. A ver, en
en el documento instalación física de
una red B.pdf.
Vale, ahí tenemos todos los conectores
estos,
¿vale? El RJ
RJ45
cable par trenzado.
LC sería fibra óptica
eh
RJ11 sería es el típico cable de
teléfono,
¿vale? Sería cable de par trenzado,
FDDI, fibra óptica.
Vale, suele tener eh conectores
específicos, pero se suele eh asociar
con fibra. FC sería fibra óptica
también,
¿vale? Y eso básicamente sería un
consolidación de conocimientos. Más que
nada vamos al tema de IPS,
¿vale? Y tranquilos al examen que que no
que tampoco es, o sea, a ver, repasar
todo esto, todas estas cuestiones que
estamos mirando estos días y no deberíis
de tener mayor
mayores problemas. Vale,
vale. Jorge, lo has enviado.
Perdón, ¿alguno más lo ha hecho?
Yo lo tengo, pero no
como en un documento, lo tengo escrito.
Vale, pues cuántalo de vez en cuando,
¿vale? Cuando os vaya diciendo,
me dices, pues esto o lo otro. Vale.
Vale.
Venga, vamos a ir a corregirlo entre
todos. Jessica, Ramón, ¿cómo vais con el
Lo tengo hecho, ¿cómo te lo envío? ¿A
través de Tame o cómo?
No, aquí en el chat mismo. Lo envías
aquí lo
Vale, te lo envío aquí.
Sí, lo empujas ahí y ya está. Lo
mando.
Ahora te lo envío.
Vale, venga.
Dios.
A ver, voy a abrirlo yo,
¿vale? No, no voy a abrir el de ninguno
de vosotros porque por razones obvias
también no vamos a corregir sobre uno
que hayáis hecho vosotros.
A ver, voy a descargarlo. Eso sí.
Vale, genial,
¿eh?
Venga,
a ver que saco este sería.
Vale, pues este,
jolín, cómo tengo la garganta.
Vale, pues empezamos por este primero.
¿Cuál sería la IP de red? Si queréis me
vais diciendo.
He visto he visto el tuyo, Jorge. Así,
así por encima y bien. Vamos, o sea, sí
que lo veo. Está guay, ¿no? Y P de red,
¿qué sería?
1.0
sería uno. Correcto. Sí. Espera que no
voy a poner comas si no 1.0.0. 0.0,
¿vale?
Su máscara de su red sería 255
pun0.0.
¿Por qué? Porque es de clase A, ¿vale?
Sería de clase A, ¿vale? Eh, ¿cuál sería
la parte de red y cuál la de host? La
parte de red sería la máscara de su red.
Nos lo está diciendo ya. Vale, la parte
de red sería el 255
y la máscara de subred, eh, pues ahí,
perdón, y la parte de host sería el
resto. ¿Vale? Entonces, tenemos
eh 200, ¿cuántas cuántas eran? 256,
¿verdad? 256 direcciones
por 256
que nos dan un total de 16 millones y
pico de direcciones.
¿Vale? Entonces, una red de clase A,
lo a ver, lo digo por repasar así un
poquito, ¿vale? Todo esto, ¿vale?
teníamos 256
* 256
* 256,
¿vale? Entonces tenemos 16 millones y
pico de direcciones que podemos
que podemos implementar mediante
mediante mediante esta IP, o sea,
tenemos ese rango de direcciones, ¿vale?
¿Qué sería? ¿Plica o privada?
Vale, porque aquí sé que teníamos que
las las públicas irían desde la uno
a la
a la 9, o sea, a la última de la del de
la 9
de la 11. O sea, quiero decir privada,
¿cuál sería? La 10. Vale, todo lo que
sería la 10,
la
de luego de la 11 a la 12, a la última
de la 126,
estoy hablando del primer objeto, eh,
porque la clase la determina el primer
objeto,
que serían esos primeros.
Si quieres te puedo mandar el resumen
que sale en el PDF.
¿A qué te refieres?
No entiendo.
Ah, para que lo para que lo tenemos para
que se vea ahí bien. Vale,
vale,
vale. Pues eso, venga. Gracias, gracias,
Jorge. Vale, tenemos las de clase
clase privada reservadas. Vale, vale. Lo
que pasa que claro, esto nos
claro, al poner esto
ya sabemos que esta siguiente sería una
una reservada y por lo tanto no
tendríamos que que añadir nada, ¿vale? O
sea,
quiero decir,
o sea, no es que no tengamos que que
añadir nada, que no es ni pública ni ni
privada, es reservada,
¿vale? Igual igual que las de 100 las
que empiezan por 127, que generalmente
pues eso, se utilizan como a modo local
host.
Yo yo había puesto que no que no era
válida. que no era válida, ¿no? Si es
reservada realmente,
no es ni pública ni privada, pero sí que
podemos poner ahí realmente realmente
todo, ¿no?
Todo su Pero bueno, o sea, es que no es
utilizable,
esta está las de cero no son
utilizables, entonces da igual. O sea,
si pones que no es válida, pues se
entiende que no es válida también. Yo yo
entiendo que eso es.
Un segundo, es que me ha llegado aquí
una cosa. Vale,
es que tenía un ejemplo también. A ver.
Vamos y las pestañas abiertas aquí.
Vale, a ver,
esto no sería
eh
de aquí. A ver.
Bueno, este es No, este es otro
que estuvimos mirando.
No, esto tampoco es. A ver,
esto no sería
y este de aquí no tampoco. Esto tampoco,
no. Es que tenía varios ejemplos de
esta, pero bueno, ya lo encontraré,
¿vale?
Porque es que tengo demasiada cosa aquí.
Bueno, transcurso de esto igual lo Vale,
tenemos
esta eh habíamos quedado en qué era,
¿vale? que era pública o privada. Esta
esta primera
eh pública.
Vale, esta la tenemos pública. ¿Por qué?
Porque las privadas,
¿vale?, serían las de las que están en
este rango en el en el 10, ¿vale? Esta
la tenemos como pública,
¿vale?
su
primera eh IP válida
tendríamos que es
1 0, perdón 1.0
punto 0.1.
Vale, esta sería la primera válida y la
última válida
sería la 1 pun 0.255.
No sería la 1 255 255 254.
Me estaba rayando. Sí, sí. No, tienes
toda la razón. Me estaba rayando con las
otras, con lo del broadcast.
y la 254. Correcto. Sí, sí. No,
disculpa, eh, esta sí que sería así.
Vale. Y luego el brasc sería 1.255
255 que estaba mirando la otra.
Vale, esto sería así, ¿vale? Su su
primera dirección válida y su última
dirección válida dentro de ese rango.
¿Vale? Luego la red en binario, o sea,
la parte de red, ¿no? La parte de host,
¿vale? Entonces tendríamos
el primer obteto que tenemos
cuál nos da el valor uno en en ese
primer obteto el último. La último
el último un
el último uno. Vale. Entonces tendríamos
siete ceros
5 3 y 2 6 7 y el último uno, que es lo
que nos da el valor. Y lo siguiente pues
nada. Vas nada, eh. 00,
¿vale? O sea, todos ceros.
Por eso
que nos dicen, dime, dime en binario la
la esta. Pues ahora lo hacemos también,
¿vale? Pero aquí estamos pidiendo la red
y la y la red sería esta sería de
segundo.
¿De acuerdo?
Vale. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
Vale,
vale. Vamos a ponerlo aquí. El sería
cero y así de paso pues practicamos
también con el con el tema de los A ver,
cero, ¿por qué no me deja escribir?
Bueno, ahora la borramos, o sea, no
sería esta. Vale, vale. Tendríamos C.
Pasa.
Hola. No me dejaba. Vale, teníamos.
Bueno, lo voy a copiar.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1
7 1 2 3 4
Dios 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1
Vale, el siguiente sería 23, ¿vale? que
tendríamos eh la primera posición
eh 16.
Claro, es que si no lo tenemos, no, la
verdad es que es un jaleo, si no lo
tenemos así preparado, porque sería,
vamos a [__] aquí ocho, ¿vale? Sería 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8, ¿no? Lo hacemos aquí. 1 2
3 4
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 Vale,
vale. El primero sería uno, segundo
sería
sería dos, el tercero sería cuatro.
¿Saben el examen no vamos a ir a esto,
¿vale? No. Ay, perdón.
El otro sería ocho. En el exen a que
calculéis en binario todo eso porque
imaginar que ponemos una tabla así pues
no da tiempo.
128.
Vale, entonces tenemos eh que poner un
uno en cada en cada espacio donde que
vayamos a sumar, ¿vale? Entonces sería
23. El 23 nos lo daría el
128 es o sea 64 32
superior, pues tendríamos ya el 16.
Vale, aquí pondríamos si me deja, aquí
pondríamos uno,
¿vale? 16
y 8
son 24, ¿no? O sea, sería uno más.
Entonces, aquí pondríamos un cer
el 8 no lo vamos a utilizar,
¿vale? Recuerdo, estamos sacando este 23
de aquí del segundo obteto que lo vamos
a poner ahí.
Vale, el cuatro sí que lo vamos a
utilizar y se nos quedaría
16 + 4 serían 20, ¿vale? Entonces aquí
añadimos un 1 + 20 + 2 22 añadimos otro
más
y + 1, 23, ¿vale? Entonces ya tendríamos
que este segundo obteto equivale a
Solo vamos a hacer este, ¿eh? porque si
no vamos a perder mogollón de de tiempo.
¿Vale? Sería 0
0 0
1 0 1
1.
Vale, el siguiente que sería 123.
Tenemos el Bueno, y como el siguiente es
123, pues ya con ese ya tendríamos,
¿vale? Aquí qué pondríamos uno,
¿vale? Porque 123 es menor que 128.
Co,
o sea, 123 a 128, ¿cuánto nos quedaría?
Cinco, ¿no? Vale, entonces 64 es
muchísimo mayor que 5,
con lo cual ponemos cer aquí cer
aquí cer
en el cuatro, ¿vale? Aquí pondríamos un
uno, lo utilizaríamos el no nos nos
sobraría uno, ¿vale? El dos es mayor que
uno. Aquí poníamos un cer y en el uno,
que es el lo que nos quedaba, tendríamos
el
ahí pondríamos un uno, ¿vale? Entonces
tendríamos que este siguiente
pondré
este siguiente obteto
sería tal que así. 1 0,
no, perdón, 1
0 0 1
1 y el siguiente lo mismo.
Había 1 0
son eh cuatro ceros
un 1 0 1. Vale, esa sería
toda todo lo que es la la dirección IP,
o sea, en el caso de que aquí os ponga
IP en binario, ponéis esto. En el caso
de que os ponga red en binario,
solamente poner eh esto en binario, o
sea, sería el primero teto en este caso.
O sea, cuando claro, si te pones solas
de clase A, ¿vale? Entonces, esta que es
de clase A, te coges el primer obteto y
lo pasas a binario.
¿Vale? Entonces voy a copiar esto ahora.
Ahora os lo pasaré este archivo.
Control control C. Espera,
voy a pasar aquí
porque está en Ariel 12 y este está M.
deja cambiar nada. Es que está como
bloqueado el documento este.
Va, y no deja absolutamente nada.
Bueno, si lo dejo. Bu.
¿Sabes qué? Lo voy a [__] de aquí.
Me lo llevo otro.
Ah.
Ya es que
ni me ha copiado la celd
Bueno, ahora
sí.
Vale, una combinación así. Vale, pues
este mismo
está bien. Vale, vale. Sí,
así podría ser.
Vale, estaba superbloqueado.
Vale, entonces cogemos este de aquí,
copiar. Y lo ponemos, lo ponemos aquí.
Digo,
a ver, es que así lo tenéis de
referencia. Imaginar que en el examen
pone
IPN binario, ¿vale? IP binario sería
esto.
Binario
solo
de
nada. Clase A.
Vale. Y esto sí que Madre mía. Y esto es
que está en formato.
Vale, voy a ponerlo todo en formato
texto
porque si no
está o como general, pero que no me lo
ponga.
Como general, pero que no me ponga los
nombre, no
el número sin posiciones decimales y sin
separadores. Vale, vale. Ahora sí.
Mira este en qué formato está.
Bueno,
bueno, ¿cómo nos vamos a ir haciendo
ahora? A ver, aquí
hoy está puñetero esto,
Está bastante retero.
Eh, bueno,
pues lo voy a intentar hacer
A ver, este, ¿en qué formato está? Es
que no me deja. Está en general.
Bueno, vamos a seguir aquí.
Vale, esto vamos a poner IP
binario. Vale, ya está.
Vale,
vale. Vamos con la con la siguiente que
sería la cero, ¿vale? Entonces, esta
realmente
esta no sería válida para un host
normal,
¿vale? Realmente entonces
no tiene no tiene mucho sentido que la
que eso que la
realmente, o sea, aquí su sería cero
serían todos ceros, ¿vale? Porque
empieza por el cero. La máscara de su
red sería igual que esta.
En principio sería sería como de clase
A, aunque realmente según la
clasificación
Exacto. O sea, iría desde la primer 00.
Va, vamos a hacer un supuesto en el caso
de que de que esto de que sirviese,
¿vale? De que de que no estuviera
reservada. Tendríamos el 0
y y un cero más. Vale, esto sería lo
mismo. 255
0 0 clase sería la A,
sería reservada,
¿vale? Ya no es ni pública ni privada.
Su primera IP válida en caso de que de
que pudiera ser usable sería 0.0.0.1.
Su última IP sería 0 pun IP válida, me
refiero, sería 255
pun 255.254.
El broadcast sería 1.255.255.255
y 1.
Y no vamos a calcular esto si no se nos
va se nos va al tiempo entero, ¿vale?
Pero realmente sería reservada, o sea,
realmente aquí sí que podríamos
tacharlo,
¿vale? Y
que si me deja sería ideal, ¿vale?
Vale. Luego tenemos la 10. La 10, ¿qué
sería? ¿Por o privada?
Eh, privada de clase A.
Esta sería privada. Espera que le voy a
quitar ya el
Vale. Y tendríamos
que sería eh 10, ¿vale? Punto 0 punto0
punto 0.
Seguro,
porque la tenemos es de clase A, ¿vale?
Y la tendríamos hasta la
hasta la 127, ¿vale? Que ahí es
realmente sería hasta la Sí, es que
sería hasta la 120
26 hasta la última de la 126.
Vale, ¿qué tendríamos aquí? máscara de
subred que sería 255.0.0.0
clase
clase a
E,
vale, primera IP válida 10 pun 0.0.1.
Última IP 10.255.255.254.
1 2 5 4
BRC. Pues nada, no voy a copiar y pegar
porque el documento este no sé qué le
pasa
que no me no me quiere dejar. Vale, aquí
también sacaríamos la 10. ¿Cuánto sería
10? En Vamos a sacar solo la red, ¿vale?
Imaginar que aquí pedimos la red,
¿eh? ¿Qué serían? Seis seis y no 8 y dos
no la
serían 1 2 3 cu aquí sería, aquí iría el
ocho, aquí iría el cuatro aquí iría el
el perdón, aquí iría el dos y ponemos un
uno y por último en en la última, ¿vale?
Entonces 8 + 2 nos da 10. Esa sería su
dirección de de red. Luego todos ceros,
¿vale? En el caso de que de que
pusiéramos la IP en binario, pues bueno,
es que si no no se nos consume la clase.
Venga, vamos, vamos así rapidillo.
Venga.
Eh, la 156, ¿vale? Habíamos dicho
que Vale, esta sería la IP de red
de la de la 156.
¿Qué tenemos? Una red de clase
eh B.
Esta sería B. Correcto.
Vale, entonces tenemos
que 156
la IPDR sería 156.
punto 234.0
pun0.
La máscara sería 255 pun
255.
0.0.
Sería una red pública o privada.
público.
Vale, esta es pública.
Aquí en el en el PDF este tenemos la
la clasificación. No es privada, por lo
tanto es pública.
No es privada ni es nada de lo demás,
¿vale? Por lo tanto, es es eso es
publicado,
¿vale? Su primera IP válida, ¿cuál
sería? La 156
punto
234.0.1.
Siempre se repite, ¿vale? El patrón este
realmente, o sea,
es Vale. Luego su última IP válida sería
156.234.
255.254.
Vale, broca sería 156.234.2
55.255.
Como es una
como es una red de eh de clase B, pues
aquí ya solo nos está pidiendo el
enunciador las de clase A, ¿vale?
Entonces aquí ya no pondríamos nada.
¿Vale? Luego tenemos la 172.
Vale,
vale. Esta, ¿qué sería?
Eh, privada de clase,
¿vale?
Pero no, pero aquí tenemos que ser
tenemos que ser pillos, ¿no? Y decir,
ostras, 265,
eso sobrepasa ya los 200
no válidas.
No es no válida. Vale, esta sería no
valida.
Aquí podríamos ponerlo todo. Bueno, no
válida. Vale, ya está.
Vale, entendéis por qué es no válida,
¿no? Por este 265.
En el caso de que aquí hubiera otro
número 255 o inferior a 255,
¿vale? sería una red de clase
sería de clase eh de clase B,
¿vale? Pero no sería pública, sería
privada, ¿vale? Porque el rango de 172
es privado.
Vale, luego tenemos la 182. Vale, venga,
vamos a hacer esta, ¿no? Vamos a esta de
aquí. Bueno, nos da tiempo hacer estos
dos. Venga, 182
punto
pun 66.1.
¿De qué es? De clase,
¿cuál?
182.
Vale, tenemos que de la 128 a la a la
última de la 191,
¿vale? Son de clase B. Entonces esta
está en el rango de de clase B,
¿de acuerdo? Entonces esta sería B, su
dirección, su su máscara de subred.
Lo mismo 255
pun 255.0.0.
Vale. ¿Por o privada?
Pública.
Pública. Vale. Primera IP válida 182
punto
eh
0.1.
Última última IP válida 182.24.255
255.254.
Se repite el patrón, ¿vale? En las,
o sea, una vez tienes tienes una de la
misma clase, pues pues
eso más o menos
no cambia, ¿vale? O sea, tienes que
tener claro lo que es la máscara de red,
o sea, qué parte es de red y qué parte
es de host dentro del dentro de una
dirección IP.
La parte de host sería aquella que es
asignable a nuestros equipos, a los
equipos dentro de esa red. La más la
parte de red sería lo que lo que
identifica esa red. En este caso sería
esta esta parte de aquí, ¿vale? En las
de clase B, en las de clase A sería el
primer obteto, en las de clase B serían
los dos primeros obtetos.
¿Vale? tener claro eso y es una vez
tienes claro eso es fácil de verlo.
¿Vale? Y luego tenemos el broadcast 182
eh, punto 24
pun 255.255.
Vale. Vale. Luego vamos a esta que esta
tiene así como un poquito más de miga.
Vale. 1918.
Esta qué sería clase B o C.
B,
vale, B también. Lo que pasa que
despista un poco porque estamos
acostumbrados a poner la 192, 168,
¿vale? Se parece mucho a las direcciones
que que solemos poner en las redes
locales
que son de clase C. Entonces, eso nos
puede despistar un poco, pero tener ahí
en cuenta esto, o sea, es un 191, o sea,
tiene muchísimas
muchísimas direcciones a asignar,
¿vale? Porque, ¿cuántas cuántas
direcciones podremos asignar en una de
clase B? ¿Como sería el caso de esta?
¿Cómo?
¿Cuántas direcciones podemos asignar? O
sea, ¿cuántas direcciones tenemos
disponibles
en un
los últimos dos dos oetos?
256* 256.
Sí,
vale.
Queo equivale a los últimos dos obtetos.
Vale, la IP de R de aquí sería 0 y luego
eh ahí, perdón, er también. Vale,
como es clase B, lo mismo. 255.
255.0.0.
Clase B por B.
Pública o privada.
pública.
Venga, pública.
Vale. 191 pun eh 168
punto, o sea, su primera su primera
dirección asignable, la uno, ¿vale? Y la
última, pues lo mismo, 1 91 pun
255 pun
a diferencia de 192, ay, perdón, 1918
255.255,
¿vale? Y nos venga, hacemos esta 192 que
esta cambia, ¿vale? Esta la 192168
1, ¿qué sería? Clase B o clase C.
C.
Venga, esta es C. 192.168 168
punto.
Lo estoy haciendo bien.
Cero
punto
no es ahí ya no.
Ahí me Ahí ahí no, ¿verdad? O sea, aquí
qué tendríamos que poner aquí tendríamos
que poner uno, ¿vale?
Y aquí un cero, ¿vale? La IP de esta red
sería esta. ¿Cuántas direcciones le
caben? Pues incluyendo la la
propia de red y la de broadcast serían
las 256
asignables, 254.
Vale, en una respuesta, siempre
matizando este tipo de cosas,
255, su máscara de red sería 255 25
tipo C.
Tipo C. Tipo C.
Pública
o privada.
Eh, privada. Vale, esta sería
privada 192. ¿Veis? 168 estaría dentro
del rango de las privadas. Generalmente
son las que nos nos solemos asignar
dentro de los
No sé por qué lo ponen
en rojo.
Vale, la primera IPA válida sería
192.168.1.
punto
1. La última
válida sería 192.168.1.254
y el block sería 192.168
punto,
perdón, punto 1.255.
Vale, pues eso, esa sería esta. Estas
otras no.
Bueno, pues eso, voy a voy guardo esto.
Vale, es que nos hemos pasado 6 minutos
ya de la
de la esta. ¿Queréis que sigamos? Eh, no
sé, me da igual. Me da igual [__] la
otra asignatura o lo veo más que nada
por los que
hacemos. Lo hacemos hasta el final y os
lo envío
como quieras.
Venga, como
venga, pues yo sí que quiero. Vale, la
200.
pun 168
punto, ¿qué sería? Un cer
o o qué sería de clase B, de clase C, de
clase
de clase C.
Esta es de clase C. Exacto.
Aquí sería 23 y luego un cer
eso. Y aquí un cer.
Vale. Y aquí por lo que veo
eh
aquí me ha rayado. No sé por qué. Yo
juraría que lo habría puesto bien.
¿Estás en la cola?
estaba. No sé cómo se no cómo se nos ha
colado esto. Bueno,
vale, tenemos eh
vale, es de clase C, habíamos dicho 255.
Bueno, a ver, realmente aquí puedo [__]
a ver si me deja. Es que ya os digo que
este
está un poco
está un poco mal este
cel. Vale. ¿Pa o privada?
Pública.
Esta sería pública.
Primera IP válida 200 punto
punto es clase C 23.
Última IP válida 200 pun 168
punto
23.254
pun 168 pun 23.255.
Vale, venga. Y luego por último tenemos
la 8 4 3 7.
Vale, la 8437 sería de clase
sería de clase A. Punto 0 punto,
¿vale?
que habíamos dicho las de clase A, eh,
su más cara que sería 255 y seguido de
de 0.0.0
sería una clase A,
sería una dirección pública o privada o
reservada.
Vale, nos vamos aquí
público
y vemos que es pública porque no está
dentro de las privadas ni tiene ningún
ninguna ni es reservada ni nada por el
estilo.
Vale, entonces es
pública.
Pública, ¿vale? Eh, la primera IP válida
sería 8.0
La última IP válida, perdón, está aquí.
La última IP válida sería 8
punto
pun 255.254
sobre acá sería 8.255.255.255
y su eh IP del primer obteto sería la 1
2 3 4. La cuarta posición es un ocho.
Ahí pondríamos uno,
¿vale? Y las otras ya las tendríamos,
¿vale?
Y bueno, ahí ya pues dependo de lo que
nos pide de lo que pida el enunciado. Si
es la IPM binario, la ponemos entera.
El siguiente sería cuatro, o sea, mira,
esta esta sí que la podemos hacer que no
hay que calcular mucho. 0 0.
Eh,
la siguiente sería
eh también la siguiente uno, la
siguiente cer y la siguiente cer vale
corresponde a la posición. El tres sería
1 2 3 4
Corregidme si me equivoco, ¿eh? Lo estoy
haciendo así mentalmente.
La siguiente sería
cuatro,
eh,
vale, el uno, el cuatro sí que lo
ponemos.
Cuatro.
El siguiente sería uno, que sería el dos
y el siguiente sería un 4 y 3 7. Vale,
creo que es creo que es correcta. Así
tenemos 1 y 2 3 y cu 1 2 4. Sí.
Un y dos 3 y 1 2 3 1 2 4. Sí, creo que
sí, ¿no?
Bueno, pues eso sería. Vale, lo guardo y
os lo paso.
¿Dónde lo he guardado?
A ver, ¿cómo? Vale, prueba.
Paso aquí por el chat.
Ah, lo has pasado, Jessica. Vale,
genial.
CP lo acabamos de de hacer ahora. Sí,
sería este. Vale, pues ahí tenéis.
Si me deja, no, porque está A ver qué le
pasa. No se puede enviar porque está
actualmente de uso. Vale, lo quito de
uso. Ostras,
se pegue fuera.
Vale. Y esta. Ah, vale. Este era el
tuyo, Jorge, que lo tenía abierto
también. A ver,
este lo cierro. Este lo cierro. Si me
deja. ¡Uf!
No guardar. No guardar.
Sí que la tenías tú como no válida. La
de la estoy viendo ahora.
Sí, sí, pero es que no, o sea, cuando
estaba viéndolo no no me había fijado.
Sí, sí, sí. Lo estoy viendo ahora que la
tenés como válida. Vale, y estoy viendo
que, vale, pone red en binario y lo que
has hecho es la IP en binario, ¿vale?
Entonces, a ver, ahí os lo dejaré ahí
más clarito, ¿vale? En el para que no
haya para que no haya confusión.
A ver,
redes IP. Esto sí que os lo quiero
mandar.
me deja ahora. Sí,
vale. Pues ahí tendríais
y lo voy a subir también a lo digo por
luego Eduardo si lecha o los que no
habéis estado.
Vale, pues dejamos hasta aquí redes hoy.
M.